[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight it's been an awfully long week
but thank God we're ending it tonight
with two pieces of good news the first
Great Britain is an independent country
again as it has been for most of the
last thousand years brexit has gone
through so cheers to our friends in the
UK in this country the impeachment farce
is almost over
that's our good news the president will
be acquitted now we knew that from the
first day of course which is one of the
reasons this whole overhyped charade was
always such an insulting waste of time
but now it's official
even the wettest Trump aiding
Republicans in the Senate are thoroughly
sick of this they want it over and yet
because once started nothing in
Washington ends easily the process
continues on like a ghost ship here was
the scene in the Senate floor today
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
those are actually retail drunk shoppers
and box stores on Black Friday but it's
the same sickness at work mobs of
desperate people grasping at trinkets to
fill a void within sad to watch let's
try to find the actual tape from the
Senate
[Applause]
nope once again right theme wrong video
Jerry Springer wasn't really in the
Senate this week but Jerry Nadler was
check out what happened last night when
Chief Justice Roberts asked prosecutors
to an safe answer a final question
Nadler an Adam Schiff raced to the
podium all but elbowing each other out
of the way to get one last blessed
moment on c-span watch this tape and ask
yourself if you have ever seen anything
with less dignity
could you please respond to the answer
just given by the President's Council
and provide any other comments the
Senate would benefit from hearing before
we adjourn for the evening members of
the Senate I want to be on TV no I do
these people are buffoons that clip
really was the whole impeachment from
start to finish narcissistic degrading
pointless a nation as great as this one
deserves more but that would require
impressive leaders at some point maybe
next week will look back on this whole
chapter in shame but for a few more days
at least the hysteria will continue in
fact it will likely increase believe it
or not the media class seem to be just
figuring out that Trump will not be
removed from office before the Super
Bowl you've always known that obviously
they had no idea they're literally
stunned over at MSNBC a person called
Mara Gay declared that if the results of
the last election aren't nullified
immediately democracy is dead forever
think about that for a minute she
clearly hasn't it's kind of hilarious
actually watch her tantrum what's on
trial is not just Donald Trump right now
what's on trial is the rule of law
what's on trial is our democracy I mean
what a sad sad moment after you know 300
plus years of democracy and by the way
truth matters I mean as a journalist I
just think that's what separates us from
Russia from Venezuela if we don't stand
up for truth now it will be too late it
will be too late as a journalist a
journalist and that was your tip that
Margay isn't just some fake Democrat
strategist they invited on a cable show
like they often do she's in fact a
member of the New York Times editorial
board enough that makes her a journalist
but she's still the best they can muster
ponder that over the weekend the
politics editor of the route calm
meanwhile told viewers that now that
Donald Trump is staying in office till
November nothing can stop him from
becoming an authoritarian dictator
imagine Donald Trump deciding some time
in June well I heard this conspiracy
theory that a whole lot of illegal
immigrants voted in California so I've
decided that during the presidential
election California has to go under
undergo extreme vetting because we can't
trust their votes we're going to shut
down voting in a state this is literally
the kind of thing he will do now got
that Trump is quote literally gonna
cancel the election in California our
biggest date okay Jason Johnson let us
know when he tries people like Johnson
are saying things like this because they
are so shocked their brains no longer
work they really thought Trump was going
to be fired at the end of impeachment
they thought he five minute phone call
Don Hunter Biden's corruption would be
enough to undo an election that a
hundred and thirty six million people
voted in like a creepy old man in a
porno theater the press the Democratic
Party allowed their fantasies to over
strip reality but they're about to be
shocked back to consciousness very soon
the Iowa caucuses are just three days
from now Bernie Sanders is likely to win
there his only real rival as a man who
should be having dinner at four thirty
at Golden Corral party leaders don't
really want either one of them Sanders
or Joe Biden their plan the plan in
Washington is to force voters to back
Michael Bloomberg a napoleonic
billionaire known for screaming at
people who drink the wrong soda none of
it seems very appealing the Democratic
Party is in trouble it's about to
collide with itself and by the way that
didn't need to happen if Democrats had
just spent the last three years coming
up with I don't know a credible plan to
lower housing prices or raise
middle-class wages or fix the student
loan crisis they might be winning the
election but they didn't do that instead
they tried the easy way out they wasted
their energy on wild conspiracies about
Russia and Ukraine and while they were
doing that their unhappiest but most
energetic activists
force their candidates to take lunatic
positions on abortion guns race gender
climate you name it positions that are
way out of the mainstream even among
Democrats it adds up to a disaster and
they know it's a disaster that's why
they're so upset the good news is as
awful and stupid as impeachment was in
the end it hurt the people who did it
most of all